hello and good morning everyone welcome
to another episode of alexa and friends
today i have julia kirshberg here with
me she is a
amazon scholar and a computer science
professor at columbia university
julius thank you so much for being here
today i'm very happy to be talking to
you jeff
awesome awesome awesome so one of the
things that uh i know
you and i chatted about very briefly uh
but that i like to do at the beginning
of these interviews
is to ask a couple of silly questions
all right so with that i'm gonna get
right into that
the first question that i often ask is
um
with uh the last 10 or 15 years or so
we've had a lot of superhero movies come
out
um and one of the things i'm always
interested to know about people
is if you could pick any super power for
yourself
what would you pick and i'd love your
story on what your reasoning is why did
you pick that one specifically
okay so i know that you asked this
question because i watched a couple of
these
and at first i thought well the
superpower i want i
thought was to be able to see what's in
people's minds
other people but then i realized
i'd rather be given that i've been home
or working from home for a long time and
i have some pets i really like to know
what my cats are thinking
because they're completely
hard to detect so either one of these or
possibly both
that's interesting so one of them you
are not the first person to say that
they want to be able to
telepathy or be able to read minds those
kinds of things
um but the one thing that always scares
about me
scares me about that is that you get to
know everything someone or something in
the case of an animal's thinking
um but that also means you get to know
everything that they're thinking and
sometimes that can be
a curse i think i think easier with
animals possibly than with people
right on people i do not want to read
their minds
right uh i agree so we have a couple of
people in the chat that are questioning
whether or not this is live or
pre-recorded
live uh i'm glad that you're here julie
okay second question
uh this one requires a little
storytelling for those that haven't
heard this story before
i want you to imagine you're in a large
congested city and you're walking to
visit some friends for lunch
you're on 17th street you need to get to
18th street
and as you as you
start to head over there you realize you
have to walk all the way around this big
city block
where there's this really nice open
brightly lit alley that you could walk
down that would get you directly to the
restaurant that you meet
so you had halfway down this alley uh
only to realize that at the end that
they were heading towards
emerges this huge horse-sized duck
right in front of you uh it does not
look friendly it does not look like
someone
you're gonna be uh pals with so you
decide to turn around like any smart
human would
you decide to head the other direction
make the long walk uh only to realize
that end has been closed by 100
duck-sized horses very small horses
so in either case you're probably going
to have a little bit of a scuffle uh
maybe just to try to escape or whatever
i'm always curious to know um where
which end would you head towards which
one do you feel like you'd have more
success at
i'd go to the duck because now i know
how to read the duck's mind
i know what it's thinking about right i
like that
actually i like ducks i like horses too
but
i've always liked ducks um then i was
working at bell labs we had
well there were a lot of geese but they
look like ducks
out around in the surrounding
uh countryside and it was really nice
just yeah beautiful so yeah i like ducks
and i
don't think they're unfriendly no no for
the most part they're not unless you get
near their nest or something like that
yes uh did you grow up around horses
well actually my sister loves horses so
i grew up around her horses
but uh yeah she had horses and she still
has horses
now she has older horses that she's
trying to keep
alive and some of them live to be thirty
so yeah arm yeah that's really great
yeah that's that's a commitment i
uh i've seen some stories recently about
how
um people that have a pet tortoise right
tortoises live forever
and how they've been passed down from
generation to generation
they have a tortoise that was around
during the civil war oh my god
that's amazing that is amazing i don't
know about those
uh all right well i i want to hear about
your career history um you've had a
quite a path that you've led
um but before that i want to add one
more little tidbit to this which is
i was just i was just talking with a
friend of mine and he was telling me
that they
based on the research um the first human
to live to be 200 years old wow
has already been born really they they
expect that
humans will be able to live to 200
before
the lifetime of everyone that's alive
today which i think is amazing wow
that's fabulous
i wonder how much longer each of us will
have
than say our parents had right well the
the the story i heard
this was probably 15 years ago now was
that if you could live to 2050
which we're still you know 29 years from
yeah um
then there will be no question of you
living to 100 years old
they think that technology will advance
enough that you could probably get to
100 now
in 2050 i will already be almost 80.
so i have to imagine that um that's
probably a guarantee anyway maybe for me
hopefully
um today is my 45th birthday by the way
i get to celebrate it with you
happy birthday thank you uh anyway let's
let's move on because i want to learn
all about you so
um the general way that i like to do
this is if you were telling a story at a
dinner party to some friends about like
what your work history was or maybe a
brief interview i'd love to hear where
you got started where you went to school
and kind of
what path you took to get to where you
are today
yeah i have a very unusual career path
um i have to start by saying that i was
interested in history
since third grade when i wrote a very
detailed history of the habsburg
emperors
all of them and they're a lot wow it was
a
i was visiting my grandmother on one
summer and she had a lot of
data on this at any rate um so i ended
up getting my first phd in history
i went to the university of michigan and
my
thesis was on 16th century mexican
social history
and i was working in a town called
pueblo de los angeles
which had a lot of very early 16th
century data
about the early settlers it was one of
the first places in mexico that was
settled
um at any rate so i had all this data
and uh while i was still getting my phd
i needed to get a job so i started
teaching
at smith college and so this kind of
slowed down my phd a little bit
but actually it turned out to be
incredibly
useful because smith college had
something called a five colleges program
and while i was teaching at the
different places
i met a really wonderful professor at
amherst college
and he was working on 14th century
history and very similar kind of
demographics
and he had a student who was triple
majoring
in history physics and computer science
wow and this kid had created
a lot of software for him in list which
was
a kind of fun to learn thing
at the time and so he offered to share
it with me
and it ended up my husband was
spending the summer um in england
because he was working in british
history so i was kind of had
lots of time on my hands and i worked
with
a student and then with others another
student at umass
on using this lisp code to actually
modify it for my use
and in the course of this i fell in love
with computer science
and i learned three other programming
languages which were popular at the time
and i just spent my whole
summer programming and as it resulted
it really helped me with my dissertation
but i also decided
because some friends said but you're a
history professor
if you're in computer science you can
make twice as much money
it was a little bit of an influence so
anyhow i decided
to go to penn where my husband ended up
teaching
and get a master's degree in databases
but they had a wonderful new program
that
they had started which combined natural
language processing linguistics
psychology and philosophy so all those
departments were involved
and i decided to get a phd in nlp
so so that's what i did
and a friend of mine and i wrote a paper
that was
published in language which at the time
was the biggest
linguistics magazine ever and some
people at
bell labs read it and were really
excited because we were working on
prosidy
and natural language processing and they
invited us up
and eventually i got a job there after i
got my phd
and i was there for 18 years
yeah bell labs has had some amazing
products come out of it too not not just
the technology but the people
yeah and the things were invented too it
wasn't really very product oriented at
the time
but i got that way as i stayed there so
we were working on text-to-speech
synthesis for a long time they were
amazing so so you get to bell labs uh
after writing this paper
and uh we we still need to come full
circle on this so today you're back to
being a professor
yes um so they asked me to start a new
department there
an hci department which i didn't know
anything about but i was the closest
person to what they thought
it was great and we had a good time uh
for a number of years but
it got to be too bureaucratic and a
friend of mine
i just attended a meeting where
the guy who was heading our research lab
said we have decided that we can
actually do research
without getting any funding from att
and the rest of us are like huh
so um a friend of mine that very
afternoon called and said she was
interested in finding somebody
to work in her department at another
university
and so i started i decided maybe i'll
start looking
and i ended up working at columbia
because my husband
by then had gotten a business degree and
he was working at city corps so it was
good for both of us
yeah that's how yeah so then i've been
at columbia since 2002
oh my goodness yeah that's another 19
years i mean you've had you've had quite
a career
i know it's been so much fun that's
great and
it's interesting to me because you're
not the first person that i've spoken
with and i i have that background as
well not
nearly the educational background that
you do uh but my undergrad is in
um psychology as well okay as as a as a
topic of interest for me and so i
often thought about that i want to get
another phd in psychology
yeah yeah i think you should uh at some
point you'll have the record for the
most phds i think but
hopefully that's excellent
but my site degree also had me gravitate
a lot towards
uh computing and research and uh
understanding how to
how to do like i have a very good friend
from high school uh who's done a lot of
really interesting research on
mapping uh human brains
like computers just fantastic uh and
human computer interface that kind of
stuff is really hard
fascinating yeah well that was our
department which i had for a long time
and that's how i learned about
hci and it kind of influenced what i
wanted to do
otherwise you know i want to learn about
what people do
and be able to take that information and
actually
do some machine learning techniques that
can actually simulate that or recognize
it
yeah yeah yeah and we're gonna we're
gonna dig into a bunch of that here as
we head a little further into this
conversation but uh
yeah i so i got an opportunity to meet
you that's really interesting
so uh so amazon scholar is something
that i introduce you as and i know
you've been almost a year now as an
amazon scholar can you
can you kind of share you know what kind
of drew you into that being an amazon
scholar means
yeah so i got into it originally because
some of my friends were amazon scholars
at columbia
and they were really happy with it and
i'm not exactly sure how i got connected
with
amazon whether they did or i don't know
but anyhow some people join
us on call me and said they'd really
like to talk about this
and so they invited me out to seattle
and i spent
a day just talking to lots of really
interesting and exciting people most of
them were remote
as we all are now anyhow so then we had
a lot of
follow-up conversations after that and
they were preparing some really exciting
multimodal
projects that i was very interested in
and some of
my friends were also going to be on
those and since i was going on
sabbatical
um starting last july um
i decided to just join so i
just joined part-time as an amazon
scholar
cool and so what what kind of
involvement do you if you can share this
what kind of involvement do you have
with amazon
what is what does the scholar program
mean to amazon what does it mean to you
well um what they tell you to or they
suggest that you do at the beginning
is just to talk to lots of people and
lots of different groups
that are in areas you're in and there's
so many different groups
in areas i'm interested in at amazon
it's just stunning
so i spent the first couple of months
just talking to people from these
different groups
and i'm still talking to a number of
them now
but i started working
initially on natural language turn
taking which i worked on before
and i've been very interested in and
now i'm also working on something else
that i haven't worked on in many years
which is um doing
dialogue act modeling from speech as
well as text
and do you know what dialogue ads are
not
so there are things like statement is is
what you said is
i said a statement is it a yes no
question
is it a w so it's very important for
people like alexa to actually be able to
understand those
what i had been working on a long time
ago was showing how
it was very important to have the speech
information as well as the text-based
information
to be able to understand what people
were saying
and what they wanted out of it basically
well cool so i know um when we talk
about areas of expertise
um you know you're you you have focused
a lot of your research and time on
things like prosody
uh inflection and rhythm of human speech
stuff like that yeah
these are topics that were relatively
new to me until i joined the alexa team
about five years ago
um you know you grow up and you hear
about words and parts and syllables
but i had never really given it a ton of
thought beyond syllables that there are
these you know phonemes and all the
other pieces that fit together
to handle a lot of this and uh it's just
it's a really interesting concept that i
wish more people understood because
it really shapes a lot of our
communication and how how
how we talk right so i know
uh you mentioned the act identification
and turn taking
um can you can you talk more about that
project and kind of
what you guys are doing with that well
with the turn taking
um i'm not working so much on that now
except with a dialogue act
identification so what we're trying to
figure out is
what is this dialogue act and what's the
appropriate response to that dialogue
app
and one thing that i've really been
interested in and talking to people
about
sorry is um something called
empathy yeah and empathetic responses
which is also something that you know is
being discussed
um at amazon uh which is wonderful
so an empathetic response empathy means
that
if i want to be empathetic with the
person i'm talking to
i understand their feelings and
if they have some problem i try to help
them with it
so for example this is very important
for things like healthcare
where people can you know maybe be a
little bit reluctant about
talking to something so if i am very
sympathetic
and empathetic they're more likely to be
able to tell me things that
will be useful for me trying to help
them
so a lot of people interested in
healthcare are really interested in
empathy
but it's not just healthcare i mean
empathy
is it's extraordinarily important
just if you want to have a good
conversation people will talk to you
more
they'll like you more and they'll tend
to come back
and talk to you again if you can
demonstrate
empathy because particularly in the time
this time of pandemic
a lot of people are either totally bored
they're
unhappy right you know and so they
really need to have some empathetic
conversations
and i think that could be very very
useful for
i agree and i mean a good percentage of
our audience
are software developers people that are
building things for alexa today right
and one of them just mentioned in the
comments that like this is one of the
reasons that i think
we continue to work on what we can
provide developers when someone speaks
to a device right now they don't have
anything
for any kind of sentiment analysis or
empathy or any of that stuff they all
they get is
hey the user wants to know what the
weather is or something like that that's
the extent of what they receive um and i
think
being able to one recognize and then to
provide that information to the people
that are building these systems
uh really can change the landscape of
how we think about a lot of these
interactions absolutely no i think it's
really important
um one thing that i worked on a lot was
something called entrainment
and this is related to empathy
you don't always want to entrain
it when you're being empathetic because
entrainment means that you're
actually talking like the other person
is talking
and we've been working on this for many
years doing research on this
like you use similar words you use the
same sort of intonation you use the same
sort of pitch range
um all these the same sort of speaking
maybe you and i
are enjoying each other people's rhythms
uh
i i would assume this also applies to
things like copying people's accents
that could be true um we didn't look at
copying people's accents too much but
actually other people have found that if
two people talk together for even three
minutes
one of them will assume the accent of
the other person
i have a very good friend she was raised
in northeast ohio
and and generally the northern part of
ohio the southern part of michigan is
considered
the neutral accent uh in the united
states
and she moved to charlotte north
carolina
10 years ago and she is 100 percent
that southern girl accent yeah anything
to hear
uh because she certainly didn't grow up
there but she's more than adopted all of
it
yeah it makes you just you know seem
more like you're
a member of the group or a member of the
community
so and people do it not thinking about
it
really oh yeah no i don't think it was a
conscious decision
but it's interesting and what we found
is that when you entrain to someone else
uh they're more likely to like you
they're more likely to think that you're
intelligent
and you actually have better
conversations and you
if it's a task-oriented conversation
you're
more likely to get it done correctly and
quickly
so i would advise everybody
think of that in training i think i want
to have a conversation with you every
week
i'm going to give it a little bit
because i know that you are involved
pretty
heavily with inner speech yes which is
coming up here really short really
quickly right here at the end of august
um can you tell me a little bit about
your role with inner speech um
kind of what you guys are hoping to
accomplish at the conference this year
well
uh so i've been engaged with interspeech
since the 1990s
i was actually running
i was the chair of isco which runs
interspeech
and i was on the board for a long time
so it's something that i've been engaged
with forever
and what we've always me and some
friends
have uh always tried to do is to make it
more diverse
uh and inclusive so now i'm part of the
inter speech well i'm part of the
organizing committee for
this next interest speech but i'm also
on a diversity committee that's been
spanning a number of years
and what we do is we have meetings
and diversity meetings that every
interspeech conference
and we also had started and me and a
friend
started something in 2016
which was we call it the young female
researchers
in speech workshop for women nice
it's for women undergraduates and
masters students because
we know um you know as there are lots of
women undergrads but as you get into
higher levels and particularly when you
go on to
phd there are fewer and fewer women it's
just true in all of our universities
who are getting their phds so anyhow we
have a day-long meeting
i guess ours will be day long although
remote this year
and we have talks with other
women senior women give talks
and organize meetings and we have
lunches with people
and we just talk to students about what
they can do
how we got how we got into our career
and what they might be thinking about
doing if they're really
interested in research so it's been
fabulous we have it now every year
oh that's great that's really good and
we're also
uh trying to a friend of mine and i
um decided a couple of years ago that
inter
that inter speech and isca didn't have
enough balance
in things like who was running who was
the program chair
um who are the isca fellows things like
that
so now we keep we keep the
statistics on all of this and it's
gradually increasing
and it's important to keep the
statistics on stuff like that because
sometimes
people don't realize you know you don't
have enough
women is good fellows you don't have
enough women program
directors so yeah yeah it's worked very
well and iska is really into diversity i
really appreciate that
um i'm glad to hear that so i have a 17
year old daughter
who's evaluating universities right now
okay
she has had an affinity for computer
science taking all the ap classes she
can in high school
uh-huh isn't sure that that's
necessarily what she wants to do but
she's good at it i
my my thought was software development
computer science
is something that's amazing to be able
to fall back on right now
code uh as you mentioned earlier you can
get paid pretty well to be able to do
that
uh so go change your dreams and if those
don't work out for some reason then
computer science is something to easily
fall back on a lot of people who come
to columbia as undergraduates don't know
that they want to major in computer
science because maybe their high school
doesn't teach it
but once they take one of our
introductory courses
we have a lot of classes that are
designed for
people who are interested in multiple
different areas besides computer science
so she is interested in colombia have
her contact me
i most certainly will i like i like the
direct recruiting that's excellent
i i i will definitely do that um all
right so
uh to pivot again let's talk a little
bit about your research because there's
a couple of things that have stood out
to me that are really interesting that i
would love to
know more about that's some of the
research you've done on things like
deceptive speech and trusted speech
tell me like how did you get started
with those kinds of topics and
what have you what are the findings you
know what's interesting
is you get onto topics sometimes that
you don't expect to
yeah so we were thinking when i moved to
colombia some friends of mine
that i knew from other organizations we
were thinking about doing some work
together on emotional speech
and we submitted a proposal to nsf
a really big proposal and
while it was being
evaluated 9 11 occurred
and after 9 11 the department of
homeland security was created as you may
remember
and the dhs wanted to prevent similar
attacks in the future they felt that
these people had gotten
in by maybe fooling
the immigration authorities which they
had
so they wanted to develop better
computational methods to help people
because people are worse than chance at
detecting deception
all people including political people
military people police unfortunately
this is well known in the in the area so
anyhow
they decided to create um a project
a multi-modal deception detection
project
and we were supposed to do they said
since we have been
were interested in um analyzing emotion
and speech they said how about doing
deception instead
and we thought oh that's cool
a modern lie detector yeah and so then
there were people
also that were looking at deception and
facial
expression and also in gesture
and other sorts of things and so they
had a large group
and we actually demonstrated that our
mod
our machine learning models that we
developed
we collected data people who were
deceiving and telling the truth
and we developed machine learning models
to distinguish between when they were
lying and when they were telling the
truth
and we could do much better than people
could on the same data
wow so after that
after a while the homeland security
people had to spend their money on
other areas and so that the air force
decided that they were very interested
in
trust as you pointed out trust and
influence
and so um we got into that program which
we're still in
and they wanted us not only to identify
deception but also what kind of speech
do people trust
and so that we also have been able to
um identify and what this shows us
is why people can't identify deception
very well
because they trust features that we have
shown to be
characteristic of lying so these are
mostly presotic features but they're
also
using some different lexical features
so anyhow we developed a game an online
game which we're using with mechanical
turk we're putting out
it's called like hatcher and so if
anyone is interested in this they should
uh sign up for to be turkers but
basically
first we wanted to just demonstrate or
figure out
whether more people than just the people
we had in our lab
were bad at detecting deception and
like catcher showed us that that was
true and now what we're doing
is we're trying to train people to
identify deception
more accurately so we give them a
question
that one of our subjects was asked and
the first
answer the subject gave and we asked
them to say
is this truth or lie and we also give
them
a normal voice of that person which we'd
also collected so they can compare that
voice to the voice they hear
and if they make if they make a mistake
and say
it's a lie but it's true we tell them
why
we give them training and the same if
they say
that it's true and it's a lie we give
them training and
we're going to put out lots of tasks to
do this and hopefully be able to get
people
at least they have fun it's a very fun
game to play i have to tell you
so i'm sure our audience would be giving
this a try if they want to find like
where would they search or where can
they find that um they could search
for um deception detection
um i think that's the name of our
i should have gotten the name of if
they're interested they can just contact
me and i will tell them where it is
but they can also just look for a live
capture
well a couple of the folks in the
audience have already found like your
columbia
professor page which i'm sure has
probably your email address on it so
expect a couple of emails
yeah that's fine uh all right that's
great so so we've talked about deception
and i know we talked about empathy a bit
earlier
some really interesting concepts but
what about something like
charisma i have been accused of having
that from time to time
um but it's the thing that you know
makes speakers attractive like
politicians and and
business leaders uh i probably could use
some training in this area i think
sometimes as well but
i'd like to know what are your findings
around charisma
so we started on this it was just a
course project with three of my students
in my course
back in 2003 so we've been working on it
forever
um and what we did then was to
um actually ask this was before you
could do crowd sourcing
and so we had our own crowd's bursting
mechanism
and we put this out and we put um
like segments of speech and also
um they could of course understand what
the person was saying
and we asked them to rate how
charismatic this person was
and these persons were at the time was a
long time ago
are running for um the democratic
candidacy for president
and so there weren't a whole lot of them
not as many as there were in our last
election
and only one was female so it wasn't
very balanced for gender
so anyhow we got some really great
results and we tried the same thing
this was on people speaking english but
we tried the same thing
on people speaking arabic
because i had a student working with me
who
could speak arabic and so he collected
the data for us
and what was really interesting was
arabic speakers
raided their charisma using very similar
characteristics that is when you compare
the voices they were very similar
of course they were speaking a different
language so we decided to have the
arabic
readers write the english so
and the english readers read the arabic
speech even if they didn't necessarily
know that language
are they well either one none of them
did
sure about that and so they rated the
charisma
in the same way they pretty much had the
same
view of charisma the features of the
voices they rated as charismatic were
very similar in both cases
it was really we also had people from
sweden do the same thing
on both of those and their ratings so
people
that the thing to conclude about this is
it's not what you say so much
as how you say it yeah that's
interesting i wouldn't have expected
something like charisma
to necessarily cross language barriers
that's
uh that's an interesting finding yeah i
know so uh
but anyhow there are people that train
people and charisma we have not
done that yet but it's um but it's
you know forgiving if you want to get a
a pitch for your startup or something
like that
a lot of people want to get trained as
do politicians
sure so recently we did do the uh
people running for the democratic
nomination
last year we even published that data
yet
but needless to say the person who won
was not necessarily the most charismatic
person
rated but he was rated very highly in
that other features like
confident and sure reliable those sorts
of things
it would be interesting to see and this
is probably a longer term effort
yeah interesting to see if the
measurements that you guys can
come up with against those candidates
could reliably predict the winner
bell we thought so too in no case have
we ever been able to predict the winner
so uh um yeah that's
uh one thing we did do though because we
were interested in gender and
obviously whether people would rate
women lower than men because there has
been
had been some work on that so we did a
study
of charisma just using things like
podcasts and things like that
courses and actually we found that it's
not significantly different but the
women were actually rated higher than
the band
so we were a little surprised but it
depends i guess on
who you have you know who's actually
yeah
yeah yeah that is interesting i i mean i
i feel like generally society
tends to sway mail anyway when you think
about
political right i mean i know look at
the
how many presidents in a row we had now
yeah
and uh we just had a mayoral election
and
two females actually came in second and
third so that was good
and then so maybe things are changing it
is progress right
yeah i think uh all right so speaking of
progress uh
you've been working in the field of
speech and natural language processing
for a while
um i'm very thankful for that where
where do you see
these kinds of technologies going in the
next five or ten years
okay um so
from my point of view i think um
well certainly particularly since i've
been at
amazon and talking to lots of people
working on alexa
i think there's a huge growing interest
in dialogue systems and i think
maybe the alexa prize has been a good
incentive for that
i don't know but uh um i'm noticing a
lot more people who are working in this
area and i think a lot more industries
want to be able to do it well as well
it's not just amazon but it's lots of
different
industries so i think that's one thing
there's also a huge interest now in
identifying bias
in ai and that's definitely
you know everybody is concerned with
this you can't even submit a paper
anymore
unless you explain why it's
you know not biased in any way against
any ethnic or gender group
and also there's a lot of interest in
doing speech and from the speech and nlp
perspective for social good
i have a friend who's also an amazon
scholar
and she's been working with people in
this columbia school of social work to
identify
the sense of loss and potential
aggression
in social media posts in chicago and
they're helping the
social workers there to identify
when people are posting something that
suggests that maybe
an intervention might be useful for them
or helpful
wow yeah no it's amazing work
um so anyhow the other thing of course
is social media
now it's huge there's so many corporate
out there that people are collecting
so we're actually doing some work um on
identifying disinformation in kobit 19
and climate change or climate gate as it
is sometimes right
now and this is really
fabulous interesting and social media
just gives you so much such a rich
source of data
yeah i mean it's just volumes and
volumes and it never it never really
ends right it's not a
finite set of data unfortunately not
and what we actually one of the
interesting things we we realized was
that you know when cover 19 started back
in
where whenever it did like
almost a year ago two years at any rate
when it started i guess it was
last fall that people no it was last
spring
i remember uh having to come back from
the netherlands
very quickly because they were going to
um
block people coming back from the front
i wasn't playing in india at the same
time
that was really hard and got it got out
just in time yeah
yeah so what we the interesting thing
that we realized
was that at the time things that were
thought to be true about code 19 were
not
demonstrably false so if somebody's
posting something where they say
you should drink bleach maybe not but
something that maybe seemed a little bit
more realistic
but now has been proven to be not very
useful
so some of those posts while they're
disinformation
or misinformation they're not malicious
in any way they're not intended to be
bad for so that's one thing that's
interesting to see
that truth changes over time
and what people should believe changes
and i hope
what people believe will be changing
over time with respect to vaccination
yeah but i mean i think and i you know
for those of us that have
subscribed to the world of science and
that's that's how it's supposed to be
there's some noise
here no not really oh okay
um but i mean if you think about science
it scientists don't know the answer on
day one
they have their theories but that needs
to be tested with data and rigor
and things do change right i mean for
forever they said don't wear masks and
they said do wear masks and it was
based on the data they had at the time
um and i think that there's a lot of our
population
that struggles with that well they're
experts they should just know
um but you know code was not something
any of us were anticipating or
really preparing yeah well i knew this
from my history days
what was true about something you know
14 centuries ago then people discover
some new data
and you realize it's different yeah
yeah but that's just academics and not
everybody
is into academics for example
i hope more people will be uh all right
so speaking of academics this
uh this is my last big question for you
um
when you think about students that are
trying to pursue a career in this field
for example my daughter especially
here's her sure what are the reasons
that you would recommend for people that
you know maybe pursue a career within
academia that's not something that i had
ever considered
um my path was to be a psychologist
until i found out what i could get paid
to be a
software developer um but when
you know when you think about pursuing
research what what are the things that
you tell students as
you've uh gone on in your career yeah
well since i've been in both academia
and the industry
i kind of know the reasons to go into
both
to either one and so what i
tell students who are interested in this
is
if you're in academia you can do
whatever research you choose
you choose your own topics as you can
tell
my just not necessarily those that are
of interest
to industry but who know i guess
deception might be
um but anyhow you need to get funding to
support those projects
and that's a challenge but also you get
to
and then you also if you're a faculty
member you get to work with wonderful
students
um but unfortunately when they graduate
you have to find more wonderful students
right the bell labs i would have
a group that stayed together for years
and it was wonderful
so that's a difference and in industry
um
you can keep working with the same
people
longer and longer if you want to and if
they're really
you think they're really great but you
do need to put the company needs first
which i discovered at
um att when they really wanted us to put
out
our tts um to make some
profit for them so that's what we ended
up doing
and it was a lot of talking to the
software developers and they say well
why did you want to do this
it makes no sense
so anyhow it was but it was fine um
so anyhow my advice would be you know
if you really think that you want to
work in academics i
would try to get as much research
experience as you can actually it's good
for academics or industry
because you can get internships if
you've got some good research experience
too so there are a lot of programs
in a group that i'm been involved with
since 2009
it's called the crawp widening
participation
and they have wonderful programs for
undergraduates and graduate students
which i've been involved in and for
undergraduates they give you a chance to
actually do research
in the summer in a university other than
your own
and the good thing about that is you get
to find out what other universities are
like and you also get
other people who can write you letters
of recommendation for whatever you want
to do later
so that's really good anyhow so
um yeah i think um
you should see what because a lot of my
students
you know think they want to go into
industry and a lot of them
when they've done a lot of research i
think they want to at least do research
in industry or um
or in academia so
i don't know my advice would be you
could try both of them
really people go back and forth two
years
and you do something else you know but i
think the key to all of that that you
kind of mentioned is that it's
it's about building a network um that is
true you
definitely need to build a network
whenever you decide to
get right i mean that's that's been
something that's been really
evident to me in my career i won't give
you the long story but
the short story is outside of my first
couple of jobs
every job i've had since has been
because of someone i worked with or
because of my reputation
um and you know like people say all the
time i need to clean up my resume
i don't even know where my resume is i
haven't done that in a while and that's
that's good for that's been great for me
i know not everybody has that experience
but by building that network and showing
you know your capabilities and your
knowledge and your passion um
it really goes a long way in furthering
your career and you get uh
you get opportunities to talk with julia
hershberg
well very pleasant talking to you too
well i want to thank you for joining us
today julia this has been a really
educational
conversation you can guarantee that you
are going to get an email from my
daughter so
okay what's her name
uh her name is riley right okay alex um
for the rest of you though um i would if
you want to know more about this kind of
work this kind of research
amazon.science
is our website that covers all of these
kinds of topics covers
all of our published papers and blog
posts and articles uh that we've been
sharing uh throughout the year
uh i know that you can also go to
interspeak 2021 that julie is a part of
um where you can see all of the accepted
papers that were available uh for this
year's conference
um and hopefully this gives you a little
bit of a feel for what some of the work
that we're doing
uh in the amazon science world there's
lots and lots of research and
opportunity
uh and we're always looking for people
to come join us and and be a part of it
so
what i have to wrap us up here julia is
a a quick video from our amazon science
folks okay
uh titled meet our alexa scientist so
julia stick around
um i'm gonna show this video and then
i'll come back and chat with you okay
my name is ola banji shonibar i am an
applied scientist at amazon
i work with the pro language
understanding service
and response team within alex's speech
my name is aparna and i'm a senior
applied scientist in the alexa speech
recognition team currently i'm working
on building better experiences for
bilingual customers
of alexa just like myself my name is
venky i'm an applied science manager in
alexa ai
me and my team of scientists work on
different paralinguistic signals
associated with voice
as we know alexa is used by many
customers
across languages across age groups with
different types of voices
we make sure we understand everyone
irrespective of their variance in their
works
hey there i'm i'm familiar science
manager in the alexa test speech
research team i joined the team three
years ago
with a task to improve the explosivity
and naturalness of our scientific voices
and this resulted in the release of the
emotional capabilities for alexa
currently i am working with many other
teams trying to push forward the
envelope of what we can do with our
technology
i'm kayoko i'm a senior speech scientist
in the texas speech team at amazon
i joined amazon five years ago and
initially worked on the launch of
amazon's first japanese texas speech
voice
in the poly service followed by the
launch of the japanese alexa and more
recently
i've worked on the launch of bilingual
alexa making
the american english alexa voice speak
spanish buenos dias
get to work on problems that are not
well defined you will be expected to
develop and deliver end-to-end solutions
you would work on problems that are on
structures and then
depending on the level uh you might be
expected to
mentor engineer colleague as well one of
the things that anyone will notice
when they work in alexa ai is the
amazing group of scientists
and engineers that we have around here
so there's lots to learn
of the last two years i've learned quite
a bit it's helped me
become a better scientist a better
thinker and a better employee
we are constantly learning new things so
we are having to adapt and adopt new
technologies not only that we are
keeping learning we are keeping
absorbing technologies from other fields
such as nlp
or computer vision there is always a
chance to learn new things so i've never
worked many of the problems that i
worked on
did not have any prior research work on
it or very little of it there are also
problems on which there's plenty of
research
available but many times the work done
on academic data sets doesn't really
translate when we work
on solving these problems for alexa
customers i really enjoy the challenge
of working on and solving these problems
and this is really what makes innovation
at the heart of what we do with alexa
nowadays
more and more machine learning
techniques are being applied across
different domains and in texas speech
we're using a lot of approaches
developed outside of the speech domain
which means that we see a lot of
researchers with completely different
backgrounds
joining us in tts
the customers uh they are placed at the
forefront of every decision we make and
so
if there is any character or skill you
think
that would enable you to be customer
obsessed that's a plus one alex is a
fantastic place for anyone who wants to
work on solving
real-world practical problems with deep
learning in the speech and natural
language understanding space
there's plenty of opportunity to
innovate and build state
state-of-the-art
solutions for some of these problems
[Music]
so julia i just want to say thank you
again for being with us here today this
has been my pleasure uh and i hope we
get to
speak again soon okay very good all
right thank you to everyone for tuning
in
uh we'll see you again very soon